la tranquillité de la petite route
cabossée dessus gobineau monténégro est
à peine troublé par l'arrivée de deux
camping-cars français à leur bord claude
et claudine suivi d'un couple d'amis
dans quelques instants
ils vont entrer en albanie le point
final d'un périple de deux mois à
travers toute l'europe pour fêter leurs
40 ans de mariage ce pays
ils en rêvaient pas besoin de visa pour
y pénétrer
une simple formalité même le douanier
est accueillant kutxa cela n'a l'air de
rien mais il y a à peine 20 ans il était
impossible pour les touristes
indépendants comme eux de franchir cette
frontière
de cette manière l'albanie est l une des
dictatures communistes les plus fermés
du monde
on s'était dit un jour on ira voir
pourquoi pendant autant de temps qu'on
ils ont réussi à maintenir ce régime
fermé mais comme vous voyez fermer les
l'instant frappe à la porte ont réussi à
rentrer donc c'est quand même bien
n'être maintenant en albanie ce qui les
attire
c'est l'histoire singulière de ce pays
méconnu une histoire qui a laissé son
empreinte dans le paysage 800000 bunker
comme celui ci sont disséminés dans tout
le pays
symbole de la paranoïa du dictateur
enver hodja au pouvoir de 1946 à 1985 il
craignait une invasion étrangère
j'ai déjà poreuse aux premiers clichés
du pays pour la petite troupe est pas
par autre sur le côté c'était prévu pour
deux personnes
eh bien c'était la corée du nord ici
l'équivalent de la cocaïne
on aime voir ce genre de choses parce
que ça fait comme on dit patrimoine mais
je pense sincèrement que pour eux s'ils
pouvaient les casser les détruire je
pense que ça disparaîtrait un petit que
quand même le monde a changé dans le bon
sens a quand même
à seulement deux jours de camping car ou
trois heures d'avion de la france au
coeur des balkans l'albanie était
jusqu'à présent ignoré des voyageurs
victime de sa mauvaise réputation mafia
vendetta et trafics en tous genres
aujourd'hui des visiteurs à l'esprit
pionnier découvre l'autre facette de
l'albanie des plages paradisiaques des
paysages d'une beauté à couper le
souffle des montagnes grandioses des
trésors encore insoupçonnées qui
pourraient faire de ce territoire pas
plus grand que la provence le dernier
eldorado du tourisme en europe
[Musique]
9h du matin sur les rives du lac de come
and dans le nord du pays
le ferry un ancien autocar transformé en
bateau va bientôt partir une seule
liaison par jour pour desservir cette
région quasi inaccessible par la route
ce matin parmi les passagers
un français tentent de se frayer un
chemin michel yves labbé le fondateur
d'une agence de voyages haut de gamme
sur internet
il vient en repérage il voudrait
commercialiser un autotour en albanie un
circuit individuel avec hôtels et
locations de voiture je voulais venir
ici parce que le trajet en ferry qui
dure deux heures entre ici et l'autre
bout du lac est paraît-il
extraordinairement beau c'est un test
voir combien de temps ça prend pour y
arriver ils ont organisé cette journée
qui à mon avis est une journée hors du
commun quand même
sur le rafiot les touristes sont encore
rares marcus 38 ans est venu seul en
stop depuis l'allemagne
je ne connaissais pas grand-chose de
l'albanie mais j'avais dans l'idée que
cela pouvait être une destination
intéressante d'autant plus qu'il ya
encore très peu de tourisme ici mais je
pense que ça va bientôt arriver
je voulais être là avant les autres
marcus est l'un des premiers à découvrir
les paysages spectaculaires de ce lac
artificiel long de 34 km
les agences de voyages elles aussi
commencent tout juste à s'intéresser au
pays
mea culpa
franchement je l'albanie on avait tous
complètement oublié la veille
moi je m'en suis rendu compte l'année
dernière rentrée d'athènes extrait dans
l'avion je regardais ont pas et on
survenait l'albanie et du tout c'est
qu'au tout ça je me suis dit mais
albanie et on y avait avait oublié
l'albanie est effectivement à partir de
ce moment là je me suis dit qu'il y
avait quelque chose à faire il faut
aller bras
[Musique]
parfois le ferry fait des haltes
inattendue pour déposer ses passagers au
milieu de nulle part
cet homme retrouve son fils avant de
disparaître dans la forêt
sur le pont michel yves labbé rencontre
un confrère
bonjour ravi de vous rencontrer
enchantée comment allez vous ça va je
vous remercie vous êtes vous du royaume
uni au du royaume uni vous travaillez
pour une agence de voyages en fait j'ai
une agence de voyages ah oui moi aussi
c'est votre première venue en albanie
oui je suis là depuis quatre semaines
quatre semaines oui j'ai fait le tour du
pays
vous avez un paysage de montagne
splendide les lacs sont magnifiques
je veux dire tous ces panoramas sont
spectaculaires et les gens sont sympas
oui très accueillants
deux heures et demi de traversée au fil
de l'eau au coeur de l'albanie profonde
dépaysement garanti
pour 3 euros 50
le tour opérateur est conquis il
inscrira cette étape dans son circuit
il lui faut maintenant vérifier si les
hôtels de la région sont à la hauteur
à 50 km de là claude et claudine les
camping caristes poursuivre leur voyage
l'état des routes étaient leurs grandes
inquiétudes mais ils sont agréablement
surpris pour l'instant il s'agit de ne
pas s'égarer dans la voyait demander un
vous avez le pardon camping albania oui
marc bouche
camping 2 le côté a embauché un peu de
langage des signes
quelques mots d'italien et de français
les hommes finissent par se comprendre
quand eux qui permettrait des cours non
rationnel
les touristes vont passer la nuit sur un
terrain de camping un camping ouvert en
2009 par un couple de hollandais
c'était le premier du pays bonjour
bienvenue en albanie par les néerlandais
d'accord anglais bienvenus et pour
l'emplacement vous pouvez vous installer
merci je vous en prie
[Musique]
pour 10 euros par jour les camping
caristes ont l'embarras du choix parfait
très bon t'as vu un peu la place qu'il
peut y avoir là bas super beau hélène et
son mari dick se sont installés ici il y
a huit ans avec leurs trois enfants
l'an dernier ils ont accueilli sept
mille campeurs
ça ne s'est pas fait tout seul il ya
huit ans les routes n'étaient même pas
boudronnée il n'y avait que deux heures
d'électricité par jour et pour laver les
enfants ça se passait à l'ancienne on
faisait chauffer l'eau ici on a vu
l'albanie se transformer notre première
visite c'était il ya 18 ans aujourd'hui
le pays est en plein essor
[Musique]
leur amour du pays dick et hélène aime
le faire partager à leurs clients
ils ont proposé aux quatre français de
rencontrer un de leurs amis
un agriculteur qui habite à quelques
kilomètres de chez eux
une rencontre avec une famille albanaise
c'est exactement le type de visite que
les français espéraient
[Musique]
mais pas rêver bonjour ya qu à 62 ans
il produit du raki une sorte de vie
locale c'est le fournisseur officiel du
camping il tient à nous recevoir chez
lui c'est important pour les albanais on
y va yak ouvre souvent la porte de sa
maison aux touristes ou la malaisie il
lui dit d'aller nous asseoir il invite
ici avec son fils sa belle fille et son
épouse il est heureux de partager son
histoire et celle de son pays avec des
étrangers c'est du bon à qui il a passé
des gâteaux avant ici c'était la
dictature et c'est est rude
quand les frontières se sont ouvertes
c'était incroyable de pouvoir rencontrer
et partager avec les autres peuples
c'est nous qui nous nous étions enfermés
dans notre propre pays avec du barbelé
partout publiés on était constamment
sous surveillance après la chute du
régime comme plus d'un million
d'albanais un quart de la population
yak et son fils ont travaillé à
l'étranger en grèce et en italie
ils sont rentrés définitivement il y a
deux ans
[Rires]
rené et claude sont ravis de cette
rencontre autour d'un verre de raki qui
leur a mieux fait comprendre la réalité
du pays
finalement c'est pour ça qu'on voyage
qui peut aussi aux banques c'est une
presque uniquement voyez le lendemain
tirana la capitale
l'étape la plus attendue de leur voyage
alors il va tirana superbe anciens
soixante huitard ils font partie d'une
génération parfois nostalgiques des
espoirs suscités par le communisme au
xxème siècle des petits frais sont là
j'avoue jeunes années on pensait que
l'avenir sera meilleur gâteau honda les
petits frissons
on n'est pas allés complètement au bout
de ce conte
lorsqu'on voulait faire des rêves qu'on
a eu les uns les autres
tirana quand même un gros gros mute
tirana une ville à l'image de l'albanie
en pleine mutation
il y a vingt ans encore il n'y avait que
deux mille voitures dans tout le pays
aujourd'hui ici comme dans toutes les
capitales du monde
le trafic est dense aux heures de pointe
disparus les anciennes barres
d'immeubles grise et triste
la ville s'est paré de multiples
couleurs tirana est passé de 200 mille
habitants à plus d'un million c'est jour
de marché
renée claude et leurs épouses se mêlent
aux habitants ils sont venus faire
quelques provisions pour leur voyage les
étals sont bien achalandés
tas de petites pêches poires les légumes
et 500
les prix défient toute concurrence
continue le kilo de cerises les kiwis
c'était pareil 60 centimes aussi c'est
sur ces les volumes et a le choix
les seuls touristes du marché sont reçus
à bras ouverts
on arrive à communiquer en plaisantant
où les gens sont contents de voir des
touristes
après c'est agréable pour d'autres
touristes l'albanie se découvre au pas
de course
dans ce quart une vingtaine de français
ils se sont inscrits un tour des balkans
ils ont 48 heures pour tout visiter et
quelques minutes pour apprendre les
rudiments d'albanais bonjour meriem dja
au programme pas de rencontre avec
l'habitant juste des visites culturelles
leur première étape de la journée
c'est un site archéologique exceptionnel
dans le centre du pays
il s'appelle apollonia c'est le plus
grand en albanie sur huit hectares se
tiennent les vestiges d'une ville
grecque vieille de 2500 ans
donc là on est au milieu des d'agora ou
égaler les principaux monuments civils
de la ville notamment le bullet ayant
que vous voyez en face ces retraités
amateurs de vieilles pierres sont
presque les seuls aujourd'hui ils ont
droit à une visite en france est menée
par le directeur d'apollonia en personne
se portent très intéressant ici pas
encore de tourisme de masse comme dans
la grèce voisine sur les plus beaux
sites
les visiteurs se sentent comme des
privilégiés
au musée d'apollonia certains n'en
croient pas leurs yeux
à l'intérieur plus de 800 pièces de
l'époque grecque romaine dans un état de
conservation remarquable
faute de moyens certaines n'ont pas pu
encore trouvé de place et doivent rester
entreposées à l'extérieur
seuls 10% du site ont été fouillés tout
ce qu'on trouve dans la muse et non
exclusif effectué la première c'est
formidable parce qu'il l'a il reste à
trouver des choses sans espoir
ça mérite vraiment d'être valoriser tous
afin d'être reçus avant de partir une
dernière surprise les attend en plein
coeur de la ville antique des bunkers
normalement on a su le sommet de
l'acropole antique de la ville mais on
est entouré de sept centres de
fortifications contrat et bien c'est là
qu'ils logique du 20e siècle
pas le temps de s'appesantir sur ces
témoignages de l'histoire récente
les touristes doivent reprendre la route
trois heures de car pour se rendre à une
centaine de kilomètres de là découvrir
un autre joyau du patrimoine albanais
[Musique]
dans une vallée encaissée berat
surnommée la ville aux mille fenêtres
un chef-d'oeuvre de l'architecturé
ottomane
[Musique]
l'une des plus anciennes cités du pays
classée par l'unesco
[Musique]
c'est très bien mise en valeur des
petites rues où on est seul c'est vrai
qu'il n'ya pas la foule de touristes
qu'on peut rencontrer à dubrovnik wire
donc et on sent cette authentique
puisque l'on vient de voir passer les
gens habitent encore dedans ce sont plus
des maisons uniquement que pour des
boutiques en albanie il n'est pas rare
que l'on ouvre spécialement les portes
des édifices religieux aux touristes de
passage
cet après midi les voyageurs vont avoir
droit à une visite privée de la mosquée
de bérat tu sais biram qui est chargé
d'ouvrir les portes dès que des
visiteurs se présente
mais qu'est ce que vous faites c'est pas
la peine
c'est l'un des rares édifices religieux
à avoir été épargné par le communisme à
l'époque toute religion était interdite
aujourd'hui le pays compte 60% de
musulmans
un islam modéré et tolérant c on est
tous frères
on ne sait pas tuer n'y égorgé n'est
même on s'entend tous bien ici regardez
moi je suis musulman et mon épouse elle
est orthodoxe à des
pour le groupe de touristes français
c'est la fin de la visite
dès demain ils seront en macédoine il
quitte la ville sous le regard amusé des
habitants on est très fiers que les
touristes viennent chez nous surtout
quand ils sont français
la france est un grand pays en europe et
cela nous fait plaisir de voir des
français
moi je suis un supporter de l'équipe de
france de football et du paris saint
germain
[Musique]
dans le nord du pays michel yves labbé
le tour-opérateur continue son
exploration
aux tortues euse mais belle splendide
on est là en pionnier quoi c'est très
agréable
faut pas être sujets au vertige quand
même il doit maintenant chercher les
hôtels qu'il proposera à ses clients
pour son futur circuit en albanie les
clients habitués à des prestations haut
de gamme
trouvera-t-il son bonheur à l'hôtel
armani
à première vue un édifice typique de
l'architecturé communiste
bonjour ravi de vous rencontrer vous
parlez anglais un peu ce magnifique avec
tous les néons la salle de restaurant
tient plutôt du réfectoire de
collectivités
donc c'est bon
l'association minière de la réception le
patron va lui montrer sa plus belle
chambre et s'il y a trois lignes et si
on rapproche ces deux lits ça fait un
lit double et là il ya un balcon
le confort est spartiate la décoration
d'un autre temps clairmarais minima le
tout pour 22 euros la nuit
loin de l'hôtel de charme qu'il espérait
comme il ya de l'eau chaude oui l'eau
chaude que la chanson c'est les hôtels
anciens mais comme ils avaient dit
qu'ils avaient refait je voulais le voir
pour voir si cette fin mais là c'est pas
acceptable
enfin je veux dire pour notre clientèle
c'est pas du toit de 7,1 sa tournée se
poursuit à shkodra une grande ville du
nord
surnommée la ville des vélos deux cent
mille habitants
tous les soirs les albanais se
retrouvent dans les rues piétonnes du
centre pour flâner ou jouer aux dominos
vous et moi
[Musique]
michel yves va prendre le temps de
goûter les spécialités de la région 60
centimes d'euro la brochette
fabuleux
le tour opérateur a repéré un quatre
étoiles ouvert il ya quelques mois
seulement
il demande à voir une chambre double
standard
la chambre semble confortable le
spécialistes vérifient quelques détails
qu'il juge essentielle comment gagner
bien c'est la bretelle la moquette jeu
faute de goût éventuelle mais là il y en
a pas trop vraiment un même des picasso
et oullins je parle pas rien que voir un
bon hôtel faut que les cintres ne touche
pas le meilleur là bas c'est parce que
ça fait pas de bruit dans la chambre d'à
côté c'est correct pour une nuit je ne
sais du ici c 4 étoiles s'affairaient
d'un bon un niveau 3 étoiles chez nous
et le rapport qualité prix et là je vous
parle a dit tarif de la chambre 70 euros
moitié moins que pour un hôtel
équivalent en france il y a même une
salle de sport dernier cri on s'attend
pas à ça en albanie et une piscine dont
les travaux viennent tout juste d'être
terminée
[Musique]
seul point noir de l'établissement une
musique dans l'entrée on se croirait pas
dans un hôtel on se croirait dans une
discothèque
ce bordel leur faim
au dernier étage la terrasse va lui
faire oublier cet inconvénient s'assure
voilà c'est génial ici et la zone
piétonne est mignonne en bas est jolie
avec les montagnes autour tout ça
revenait dans un pays musulman où on est
tolérant
hoballah colle on peut pas en terrasse
on mange ce qu'on veut les pins sont pas
voilées d'ailleurs ça
bougez l'albanie en tout cas son agence
commercialise désormais un circuit de 5
jours en albanie pour un peu plus de 700
euros location de voitures hôtels et
veulent compris le potentiel touristique
du pays
d'autres français y croient aujourd'hui
en particulier dans le sud au bord de la
mer ionienne une côte escarpée parsemé
de criques sauvages
surnommée la riviera albanaise des
plages préserver de toute exploitation
hervé loiselet est tombé amoureux de la
région
on va arriver
chez parrot c'est un des plus beaux
villages du sud de l'albanie c'est un
nid d'aigle on va dire et
[Musique]
hervé est français depuis dix ans il
travaille comme décorateur à tirana il a
décidé d'investir dans le village de
chez parrot il y a acheté une résidence
secondaire et bien d' aménager une
chambre d'hôtes les albanais
généralement ne devant pas aux étrangers
il aime bien garder leurs maisons pour
eux parce que c'est vraiment c'est très
important pour eux donc moi j'ai une
chance inouïe de pouvoir acheter cette
maison
village et est quasiment abandonné il ya
il va y avoir une vingtaine d'habitants
pas plus village
voilà moi je suis là haut encore plus
haut
la route ne va pas plus loin
hervé doit faire les derniers mètres à
pied tout le voisinage des sens pour
l'aider à transporter ses bagages et à
ouvrir sa maison il est le seul étranger
de che part au haut débit
l'accueil n'était pas si chaleureux
construisait je faisais des murs quand
je partais y casser les murs donc avec
beaucoup de diplomatie
finalement je fais ça en deux ans donc
c'est énorme jalousie méfiance envers
les étrangers
aujourd'hui ils vivre en bonne harmonie
le plus important pour nous c'est que
bientôt des français des anglais des
allemands vont venir ici là nous sommes
prêts à les accueillir et à travailler
c'est une relation réciproque gagnent en
contrebas de sa ville a acheté pour 16
mille euros hervé a aménagé une petite
maison d'hôtes où il peut loger quatre
personnes il espère pouvoir la loue et
350 euros par semaine donc il ya deux
leviers qui font canapé c'est très
simple petite cuisine gmt une maison
tout confort mais hervé doit composer
avec un réseau de distribution d'eau
défaillant il était le problème c'est
qu'il ya une demi-heure d'eau par jour
mais j'ai trois mille litres d'eau de
réserve donc savage arriva j'arrive à
tourner avec l'eau sans problème il ne
compte pas s'arrêter en si bon chemin
il a déjà de nouveaux projets
d'investissement dans le village ça
c'est là c'est super c'est magnifique
hervé voudrait acheter cette maison pour
son jardin et surtout pour sa situation
exceptionnelle
[Musique]
mais derrière ce décor de carte postale
en plein coeur du village une autre vue
pourrait bien heurter ses futurs clients
je vous amène à la face cachée de chez
parrot c'est à dire un grand un grand
problème ici en dans le sud de l'albanie
est un peu partout c'est qu'il ya pas de
bennes à ordures
donc les gens y laissent leur poubelle
comme ça c'est pas possible je dire les
touristes c'est ce qu'ils voient en
premier le dire il voit le giron peux
pas c'est pas possible
les déchets un fléau dans tout le pays
en pleine campagne aux abords des
rivières dans les décors majestueux des
montagnes sur les lacs
où en pleine ville parfois à quelques
mètres seulement des habitations partout
le même spectacle de décharge à ciel
ouvert
[Musique]
vingt ans après être sortie du
communisme le pays a plongé de plain
pied dans la société de consommation et
faute de moyens a bien du mal à gérer
ses déchets l'afdl est l'un des
principaux militants pour la défense de
l'environnement
il nous a donné rendez-vous dans la
périphérie de tirana vous voyez ces gars
là regardez ce n'est pas une façon de
nettoyer on a de si beaux paysages sans
compter d'incroyables ressources en eau
ce qui est une vraie richesse pour ce
pays mais quand vous voyez toutes ces
ordures qui se déverse dans la mer
tout cela affecte le tourisme sans
parler des problèmes de santé publique
et de l'image que cela donne du pays
c'est un vrai défi que de changer cette
situation
pour l'instant l'environnement ne semble
pas encore être la priorité des
autorités
à tirana sur la place mère teresa
baptisé ainsi en l'honneur de la
religieuse d'origine albanaise
nous retrouvons claude et ses amis ils
partent à l'assaut d'une pyramide celles
construites par la fille du dictateur
enver hoxha en mémoire de son père un
monument aujourd'hui à l'abandon
c'est tentant quand même non
pour ce marathonien amateurs la montée
se fait facilement crois pas de vitesse
pour la descente
chacun son style
tu prendras pas de vitesse à ce titre
met de l'eau tu profites tu prendras pas
de vitesse là je suis tellement disparu
ça méritait le détour
pour eux le voyage est terminé
dès demain ils reprendront la route pour
la france